yeah I know kids it's it it's it was
weird being on that show because it felt
like like it was more community theater
like I just felt like just we weren't
like we weren't on a show because
because Foxton yes that it's also just
you just you know even on the streets it
seemed you know I think in retrospect
you know it was a good thing but at the
time I just didn't feel like you know no
because I didn't support it whereas we
called it the bastard child yeah rocks
we didn't we didn't hear from them which
is also great great you didn't hear from
them too much so we could do what we
wanted to do yeah but yeah we kind of
flirt left to her own devices there but
here's here's a testament to what we did
do there are people that are still
diehard fans and think about where we
would be if YouTube and all that had
been around and Twitter and everything I
mean because look we were the first ones
to do the music parodies way before yeah
and so it's like all of that stuff would
have been posted and sadly the only
thing that's out there now is what some
folks managed to get on her VHS or
whatever and get it up on YouTube and
they are I mean they're their mega hits
out there yeah still no I'm not saying
that you know I'm not saying that it was
I was that I was embarrassed to be on
the show or anything like that I loved
that it's a big chunk of my life I was
like yeah eight years of let's take more
medical school or something you know the
whole you know and I met that was my
introduction to comedy on in any level
on television or really and I think
what's cool is I don't think maybe you
understand the international appeal of
it cuz all my family in the Philippines
they're all my friends that know you
they know you from MADtv yep because it
was on there yeah yeah cool that yeah
you don't you think you're doing
something so small but well it's at
Hollywood Center studios were you there
the whole time no you're over it came on
season four all right so
was over what is it Bronson Ronson yeah
yeah first yeah now when you how'd you
uh did you how did it happen to do they
just could you go right to testing or
did you audition a thousand testing was
my sixth audition yeah cuz I did like
nine did you really yeah and people
don't believe me with it but I go and
once there twice three times a week as
if yeah I was taking a class job
yeah it was intense yeah and I remember
I guess it would have been the fifth
audition where they like sent me home
and I I went home and cried so hard cuz
I'm like they made a mistake
they've made a mistake they weren't
supposed to send me home they just
seemed enough you know yeah yeah and
then I got the call to come test the WoW
but they let sent you home because they
do you know what it was one of those
situations where like we don't want we
won or so bad we don't wanna ruin it so
just let us send her home well I done it
you know how you did the same thing over
and over until finally I remember I
think it was that fifth one where you
had to do impressions and David
saltzman's in the room yeah and you know
he's like you do I think you had to do
three yeah and I did whatever I think I
had maybe four or something but I did
them and he goes you got anything else
[Laughter]
anything else you [ __ ] we're
perfect yeah but I yeah I'm like yeah
yeah I got something else oh wow
what do you want me to do that's my
something else you tell me what to do
and I'll do it
Wow and so like he of course throws out
Madonna yeah so I rised all over the
floor and yeah yeah yeah just I don't
even remember what else but I just took
you know like took whatever they gave me
and gave him something yeah just to show
that I'm a player y-yeah yeah you know
but yeah I just remember being scared
all the time at the auditions yeah just
be frightened the whole time at the show
too but didn't but you know here's the
thing though also thinking actually in
the room when I'm actually doing it for
some reason it didn't that was fine I
mean obviously if that if I that if I
let that affect me I wouldn't have
forgotten it
yeah but for some reason I'd walk in it
and went okay I feel comfortable and I
know that I'm giving something different
when it's a bunch of white dudes it's
not being real a couple black guys a
bunch of white dudes and people being
Asian you have the confidence in that
situation because you go I'm the only
one here like this yeah and this is
gonna be as an asset this is gonna help
me get it especially because it was a
very different for the time at least I
would say I mean you name another Asian
guy that's ever been on a sketch show
after that never
holy cow Bobby are you it numbness
saying that though I'm not saying that
over it obviously there was color for
like a season very short yes Stephen is
in Fred Armisen says he's 16 Japanese
there's no holy you are kidding me
yeah do you believe that SNL has never
had an Asian cast member Wow think about
that though think about how all those
years no not one I still think that's
why MADtv was ahead of its time yeah way
more diverse more relatable just the
overall more diverse having a diverse
cast and writers gives you the platform
then to do stuff and to go where other
shows can't go because they can't you
know I mean I was even able to play a
snow snowflake you know which was like
it with a white woman that talks black I
mean it was written by Devon Shepherd I
love Devon yeah
so much yeah but so we were able to do
so much more
mm-hmm because we really were that
melting pot that you know yeah yeah and
it's um
it because I also imagine like I had
never really done anything like no
acting classes really or anything like
that
and never been on television so when
you're like that's your first real
introduction to it yeah your Lord trying
to learn everything
wait before you audition you what you
came into the seventh season did you
watch it religious no but I remember
waiting tables in La Jolla and I
remember Megan Lee the lady that owns my
restaurant
say when MADtv first came out I watched
him more than SNL or whatever right and
I remember her distinctly saying that so
that when I was when I got the show I
went down there to thank her for hiring
me as a waiter but all because she liked
am a TV
[Music]